now there's like people that are like
ever since I was a little kid I would
vote for you and as a little kid and I'm
like oh my gosh like have I been doing
this that long from Carrie Underwood
holding it down as the queen of the
CMT's to Bret Young's major collab with
boys to men et is breaking down the best
moments of the 2019 CMT Awards
[Music]
the iconic R&B group took the stage
alongside Brett young to perform an
epically harmonious version of his hit
single wrapped around you Jabba khatai
it's a great time great energy you must
have been pinching yourself I mean I
know you're a big star too but I mean
you know these guys are like it's so
much pressure on myself anyways with
with shows like this but the fact that
they're up there I'm even like twice
three times four times more terrified
and that just was so much fun that went
so perfectly and I feel like honestly
feel like I just walked off the mound
after nine innings shutout no-hitter
like I got that kind of like 18-year old
adrenaline going right now which I
haven't which I haven't felt in 20 years
so that feels really good
Julia Michaels not only won her first
CMT award for best collaborative music
video for her hit song coming home with
Keith Urban but it marked her first
award ever one for her music
congratulations on your win thank you so
much video you're still like on cloud
nine I came anything my hands haven't
stopped shaking since I got here I can't
really I this is the first award I've
ever won so um is it really the very
first one dan + Shay sweetly thanked
their wives after winning a duo video of
the year for their hits speechless the
real stars of the video are wives over
here Hannah and Abby it's crazy the past
year it kind of all started with CMC
newcomer Ashley McBride hilariously
stole loot combs beer while on her way
to accept her award for breakthrough
video of the year for girl going nowhere
I'm always awkward in and I usually
bring my drink with me but I didn't have
a drink so I took Luke Combs to drink
boys learned is don't ask questions it's
kind of my biggest thing just let it
happen
if it's guy
[Music]
Marren Morris and Sheryl Crow had a
major girl-power moment together
performing their new song prove you
wrong I just you know looking over and
seeing my idol giving me that kind of
like in she's just you know and I
obviously have no voice tonight so she
was taking the majority of the vocals so
I'm just so appreciative and I love
Sheryl so much I consider her more than
like an inspiration I consider her now
to be a friend so feel very cool to say
that as an OG queen of country Tanya
Tucker took the stage with Martina
McBride
raelynne Trisha Yearwood Brandi Carlile
and more to perform Delta dawn
[Music]
this is really the pinnacle of my year
for me I mean I could sing Delta dawn
you know how old I was when I started
singing Delta dawn on with me it had
such an influence on me and tonight on
singing it with Tanya Tucker on stage at
the CMT's and I'm blown away Carrie
Underwood one female video of the year
for the fifth consecutive year for cry
pretty on the cry pretty video this was
one that was very very near and dear to
my heart and very important to me he was
with Carrie backstage after her big win
that's crazy yeah I think yeah that's
crazy
it's the 20th award yes you're kind of
popular Carrie I well my husband was
like oh my gosh like you're your fans
day if they like to vote and I'm like
well that's how I'm here in the first
place like they've been voting for me
since day one since I was on American
Idol so they know the drill
[Music]